TUCKER IS UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
FOR MANY OF US, THIS HAS BEEN
ONE OF THE SADDEST AND MOST
PAINFUL WEEKS IN MEMORY.
DEPRESSING DOESN’T EVEN BEGIN TO
DESCRIBE IT.
WE HAVE WATCHED AS MOBS OF
VIOLENT CRETINS HAVE BURNED OUR
CITIES, DEFACED OUR MONUMENTS,
BEATEN OLD WOMEN IN THE STREETS,
SHOT POLICE OFFICERS AND STOLEN
EVERYTHING IN SIGHT, STEALING
EVERYTHING.
HOW MANY INNOCENT AMERICANS HAVE
THESE PEOPLE HURT?
HOW MANY HAVE THEY MURDERED?
WE DON’T KNOW THAT NUMBER BUT IF
THE COUNTRY ITSELF THAT SO MANY
WORRY ABOUT AT THIS POINT.
AFTER WE WATCHED WHAT’S HAPPENED
OVER THE LAST WEEK, HOW DO WE
PUT THIS SOCIETY BACK TOGETHER?
CAN WE?
WE DON’T KNOW THAT EITHER.
IF YOU ARE GRIEVING FOR AMERICA
TONIGHT, YOU ARE NOT ALONE.
MILLIONS FEEL THE SAME WAY YOU
DO.
SO MANY OF OUR LEADERS, BY
CONTRAST, ARE NOT GRIEVING.
THEY SEEM EXHILARATED, THEY FEEL
NOTHING AS OUR NATION DESCENDS
INTO ANARCHY.
THEY SEE A CHANCE TO SOLIDIFY
THEIR CONTROL TO INCREASE THEIR
MARKET SHARE TO WIN OUR
COLLECTIONS.
THEY HAVE NO INTEREST IN TALKING
ABOUT THE DETAILS ABOUT WHAT IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING OUT THERE ON
OUR STREETS.
IN FACT, THEY ARE HIDING THOSE
DETAILS, DEMANDING THAT YOU
FORGET WHAT YOU SAW.
DON’T FORGET IT, REMEMBER ALL OF
IT.
EVERY BIT BECAUSE IT’S PROOF OF
WHO THEY ARE.
THIS IS WHO THEY ARE.
[SIRENS]
>> NO JUSTICE, NO PEACE!
>> Tucker: THAT’S WHAT THEY’RE
DEFENDING.
THAT’S WHAT THEY’RE ENCOURAGING.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH CIVIL
RIGHTS, IT’S VIOLENT AND THE
CRIMINALS YOU JUST SAW ON THE
SCREEN ARE NOT PROTESTERS.
THE PEOPLE CHEERING THEM ON FROM
THEIR TV STUDIOS HAVE NO
PATIENCE FOR REAL PROTESTS, FOR
REAL PROTESTERS.
JUST IN APRIL, DEMOCRATS IN NEW
JERSEY ARRESTED A WOMAN FOR
TRYING TO PLAN A RALLY, A
PROTEST AT THE STATE CAPITAL.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IT SAID
NOTHING WHEN THEY DID THAT
BECAUSE THEY APPROVED.
THAT’S HOW THEY REALLY FEEL
ABOUT ANY POLITICAL EXPRESSION
THEY CAN’T CONTROL, THEY CRUSH
IT.
WHAT THEY SUPPORT IS MORE
POWERFUL THEMSELVES AND THEY ARE
WILLING TO USE GANGS OF THUGS TO
GET IT.
HERE’S ONE OF THEIR PROTESTERS.
>> [BLEEP]!
[BLEEP]!
NO JUSTICE, NO PEACE.
>> Tucker: NBC NEWS WOULDN’T
SHOW YOU THAT VIDEO EVER,
NEITHER WITH CNN UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES.
NO JUSTICE, NO PEACE, THEY CHANT
AS A MAN TORTURES A DOG.
THESE ARE THE WORST PEOPLE IN
AMERICA AND OUR LEADERS HAVE LET
THEM DO WHATEVER THEY WANT.
SO OF COURSE THEY WANT MORE.
THEIR LATEST DEMAND IS THAT WE
ELIMINATE THE POLICE ENTIRELY.
NO MORE LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT WOULD MEAN MORE POWER FOR
THE MOB.
THEY CAN DO ANYTHING.
IT WOULD MEAN NEVER ENDING
TERROR FOR YOU AND FOR YOUR
FAMILY.
THAT’S WHY THEY WANTED.
WATCH.
>> OUR CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS AND
ALL OF OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS, D
FUND OF THE POLICE!
>> D FUND THE POLICE!
>> Tucker: NO SANE PERSON
WOULD DARE TO HAVE SAID
SOMETHING LIKE THAT IN PUBLIC
JUST A WEEK AND A HALF AGO.
NOW A MEMBER OF CONGRESS HAS
ENDORSED THE IDEA, RASHIDA
TLAIB.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO OUR COUNTRY
IF WE ELIMINATED
LAW-ENFORCEMENT?
OF THE MAYOR OF LOS ANGELES, THE
SECOND-BIGGEST CITY IN AMERICA,
HIS CITY WOULD DEVOLVE INTO A
MURDEROUS HEALTH SCAPE WITHIN
HOURS IF THE POLICE LEFT.
BUT HE WON’T PUSH BACK AGAINST
THIS IDEA, INSTEAD HE KNEELED
AND SUBSERVIENCE BEFORE THE
PEOPLE DEMANDING IT.
>> L.A. MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
JOINED PROTESTERS MOMENTS AGO,
WHAT HE HAD TO SAY?
>> HE CAME OUT THIS MORNING AND
HE TOOK THE TIME TO COME OUT AND
COME OUT AMONG THE PROTESTERS,
HE KNELT WHILE HE WAS OUT THERE
SAYING AND SHOWING HIS
SOLIDARITY FOR THE MOVEMENT, FOR
THE PROTESTERS HERE TODAY AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT TODAY, THIS
DAYTIME PROTEST HAS BEEN VERY
PEACEFUL, VERY CALM, LOTS OF
CHANTING, SINGING.
>> Tucker: HE KNEELED.
OUR LEADERS ARE KNEELING BEFORE
THE MOB.
THE ATAVISTIC RITUAL OF SELF
ABASEMENT, OF DEFEAT.
SUDDENLY MANY ARE PERFORMING
THIS RITUAL INCLUDING POLICE
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THE MOB WANTS VICTORY BUT MORE
THAN THAT, IT WANTS THE TOTAL
HUMILIATION OF ITS ENEMY.
>> I WORK FOR BLACK LIVES
MATTER, I’M SORRY THAT I SCARED
YOU.
BUT SINCE I WORK FOR THAT
COMPANY, MY CEO HAS TOLD ME TO
COME OUT TODAY AND TO BRING YOU
ON YOUR KNEES BECAUSE YOU HAVE
WHITE PRIVILEGE SO IF THEY SEE
THAT A WHITE PERSON IS GETTING
ON THEIR KNEES, THAT SHOWS
SOLIDARITY FOR THE SITUATION.
THE SITUATION, COULD YOU JUST
PLEASE APOLOGIZE FOR YOUR WHITE
PRIVILEGE?
JUST APOLOGIZE.
>> I’M TRYING TO THINK OF THE
RIGHT WORDS TO SAY.
>> IT’S BIG.
IT’S LARGE IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: WHY DO WE KNEEL?
WE KNEEL BECAUSE WE’VE LOST.
WE KNEEL BEFORE OUR VICTORS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE WON.
WE’VE PUT DOWN OUR RESISTANCE,
WE BEG FOR THEIR MERCY BUT MOBS
RARELY FORGIVE.
WE ARE ON YOUR SIDE, WE SHOUT.
WE ARE IN SOLIDARITY, SPARE US.
BUT THEY NEVER DO.
>> WE ARE ON YOUR SIDE!
WE ARE ON YOUR SIDE!
>> Tucker: WE ARE ON YOUR
SIDE, AS THE ROCK COMES THROUGH
THE WINDOW.
DO YOU THINK THE MOB CARES?
NO.
WHY ARE AMERICANS SURRENDERING
TO VIOLENT MOBS?
BECAUSE THEY’VE BEEN TOLD THEY
HAVE TO.
EVERYTHING WE ARE NOW WATCHING,
THE LOOTING, THE ARSON, THE
KILLING HAS A PURPOSE.
THE PURPOSE, WE ARE TOLD AGAIN
AND AGAIN IS TO END RACIST
POLICE VIOLENCE AGAINST
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
WE ARE TOLD THAT THAT IS THE
SINGLE GREATEST COURAGE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> FOR THE PAST 400 YEARS, THIS
HAS BEEN A OF BLACK PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> I’M SICK AND TIRED OF SEEING
BLACK MEN AND WOMEN BE KILLED
AND NOTHING BE DONE ABOUT IT.
>> STOP KILLING US!
STOP KILLING US!
>> Tucker: "STOP KILLING US."
IT’S CHILLING AND IF YOU BELIEVE
IT AND YOU’RE A DECENT PERSON
YOU WILL BE MOVED BY IT.
BECAUSE IT’S AWFUL.
NO AMERICAN SHOULD EVER BE
MISTREATED BY THOSE IN
AUTHORITY, MUCH LESS KILLED.
THE ABUSE OF POWER IS ALWAYS AND
EVERYWHERE A SIN AND ITS
INCREASINGLY COMMON HERE.
WE SHOULD ALWAYS WORK TO END IT.
IN THIS CASE, THE DEATH OF A MAN
AT THE HANDS OF POLICE IN
MINNEAPOLIS TURNED OUT TO BE A
METAPHOR FOR ABUSE OF POWER.
THAT DEATH HAS LED TO DEMANDS
THAT WE FIRE THE NEARLY 700,000
POLICE OFFICERS WHO WORK IN THE
UNITED STATES AND THAT WE FREE
THE MILLION AND A HALF CRIMINALS
WHO ARE NOW BEHIND BARS.
IN AMERICA, JOE BIDEN TOLD US
RECENTLY, "JUST THE COLOR OF
YOUR SKIN PUTS YOUR LIFE AT
RISK."
SENATOR CORY BOOKER OF NEW
JERSEY STRONGLY AGREED WITH THAT
QUOTE.
WE HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE IN OUR
COUNTRY, BOOKER SAID YESTERDAY,
OPEN AFRICAN-AMERICAN MEN,
MOSTLY UNARMED BEING MURDERED BY
POLICE OFFICERS IN NO WAY OF
HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
SO MANY PEOPLE MURDERED BY
POLICE OFFICERS, UNARMED."
YOU’RE HEARING A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN AUTHORITY TELL YOU THAT EVERY
DAY, EVERY HOUR.
ONE GROUP OF PRO ATHLETES JUST
ANNOUNCED THAT "IT SEEMS LIKE
EVERY WEEK A NEW TRAGEDY UNFOLDS
BEFORE OUR VERY EYES WHERE
PEOPLE ARE BEING KILLED BY
POLICE VIOLENCE."
EACH TIME WE TWEET, WE PRAY, WE
MOURN ONLY TO REPEAT THE CYCLE A
FEW DAYS LATER."
IN THE WORDS OF THE LAWYER
REPRESENTING GEORGE FLOYD’S
FAMILY IN MINNEAPOLIS, "WE ARE
WITNESSING HERE IN AMERICA IS
"."
IF YOU BELIEVED THAT YOU MIGHT
UNDERSTAND THE RIOTS NOW IN
PROGRESS.
THERE IS NOTHING WORSE THEN
GENOCIDE.
IS THIS HAPPENING, IS IT TRUE?
WE FOUND THE NUMBERS AND WE ARE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THEM WITH
YOU IN SOME DETAIL TONIGHT
BECAUSE IT’S WORTH IT.
SINCE 2015,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HAS
MAINTAINED A COPPER HANDS OF
DATABASE OF FATAL POLICE
SHOOTINGS IN THIS COUNTRY.
LAST YEAR THE POST LOGGED A
TOTAL OF 1,004 KILLINGS.
OF THE 802 KILLINGS IN WHICH THE
RACE OF THE POLICE OFFICER AND
SUB SUSPECT WAS NOTED, 371 OF
THOSE WERE WHITE.
236 WERE BLACK.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE
KILLED WERE NOT IN FACT UNARMED,
THE VAST MAJORITY WERE ARMED AND
AFRICAN-AMERICAN SUSPECTS WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE A DEADLY WEAPON THEN WHITE
SUSPECTS YET MORE WHITE SUSPECTS
WERE KILLED.
OVERALL THERE WERE A TOTAL OF
PRECISELY TEN CASES IN THE
UNITED STATES LAST YEAR
ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IN WHICH
UNARMED AFRICAN-AMERICANS WERE
SHOT BY THE POLICE.
NINE MEN AND ONE WOMAN.
AS WE SAID, A LOT IS AT STAKE.
THE COUNTRY IS AT STAKE.
WE WANT TO TAKE THE TIME NOW TO
GO THROUGH THESE CASE-BY-CASE.
INTO THE SPECIFICS.
THE FIRST WAS A MAN KILLED BY AN
KNOXVILLE POLICE OFFICER CALLED
DAYLEN WILLIAMS.
ACCORDING TO WILLIAMS, HE
ATTACKED HIM, CHOKED HIM AND
USED A TASER ON HIM BEFORE THE
OFFICER SHOT HIM.
FIVE EYEWITNESSES CORROBORATED
THE OFFICER’S CLAIM AND THE
OFFICER WAS NOT CHARGED.
THE SECOND CASE CONCERNS A MAN
CALLED MARCUS McVEIGH, BY ANY
DEFINITION OF A CAREER CRIMINAL.
AT THE TIME HE WAS KILLED HE WAS
WANTED ON DRUG DEALING CHARGES,
A TEXAS STATE TROOPER PULLED HIM
OVER.
HE FLED ON HIS CAR AND THEN FLED
ON FOOT INTO THE WOODS, THERE HE
FOUGHT WITH THE TROOPER AND WAS
SHOT AND KILLED.
THE OFFICER WAS NOT CHARGED IN
THAT CASE.
FEMALE POLICE OFFICER ARRIVED
AND ORDERED THE SUSPECT TOWARD
HER CAR, HE CHARGED HER AND
KNOCKED HER TO THE GROUND.
AT THAT POINT SHE SHOT AND
KILLED HIM, THE ENTIRE INCIDENT
WAS CAUGHT ON BODY CAMERA, THE
OFFICER WAS NOT CHARGED.
BEING APPROACHED BY TWO
L.A. COUNTY DEPUTIES WHEN HE
BACKED INTO ONE OF THEM WITH HIS
VEHICLE, THE DEPUTY WAS CAUGHT
IN THE CAR DOOR, HE AND HIS
PARTNER OPENED FIRE, THE
DEPUTIES WERE NOT CHARGED IN
THAT CASE.
MELVIN WATKINS OF EAST BATON
ROUGE LOUISIANA WAS SHOT BY A
DEPUTY AFTER HE ALLEGEDLY DROVE
HIS CAR TOWARDS A DEPUTY AT HIGH
SPEED, THE DEPUTY WAS NOT
CHARGED.
ISAIAH LEWIS WASN’T JUST
UNARMED, HE WAS COMPLETELY
NAKED.
HE BROKE INTO A HOUSE AND
ATTACKED A POLICE OFFICER.
THE POLICE TASED WILLIAMS BUT HE
KEPT COMING AT THEM AND
ATTACKING COME OF THE OFFICER
SHOT HIM, THEY WERE NOT CHARGED.
TATIANA JOHNSON -- JEFFERSON WAS
SHOT BY A FORT WORTH DEPUTY.
A NEIGHBOR CALLED A NONEMERGENCY
NUMBER AFTER SEEING HER DOOR
OPEN.
POLICE ARRIVED, JOHNSON SAW THEM
APPROACH FROM A WINDOW AND WAS
HOLDING A GUN AT THE TIME.
ACCORDING TO BODY CAMERA
FOOTAGE, THE OFFICERS SHOT
JOHNSON WITHIN SECONDS.
JEFFERSON.
THAT OFFICER HAS BEEN CHARGED
WITH HOMICIDE.
CHRISTOPHER WHITFIELD WAS SHOT
AND KILLED IN LOUISIANA, HE
ROBBED A GAS STATION.
DEBBIE DECLAN SIMPSON SAID HIS
GUN DISCHARGED ACCIDENTALLY.
SIMS, WHO IS BLACK HIMSELF, WAS
NOT CHARGE IN THAT KILLING KEVIN
MASON WAS SHOT BY POLICE DURING
A MULTI-HOUR STAND OFF VERY
MASON TURNED OUT NOT TO HAVE A
GUN, MASON CLAIMED TO HAVE A
GUN, CLAIMS TO BE ARMED AND
VOWED TO KILL POLICE WITH IT.
THEY BELIEVED HIM, MASON HAD
BEEN IN A SHOOT-OUT WITH POLICE
YEARS BEFORE.
AND FINALLY, THE TENTH CASE
CONCERNS GREGORY GRIFFIN, SHOT
DURING A CAR CHASE.
THE OFFICER CLAIMS HE SAW
SOMEONE POINTING A GUN AT HIM.
LATER, A GUN WAS IN FACT FOUND
INSIDE THE VEHICLE AND THE
OFFICER WAS CHARGED ANYWAY WITH
AGGRAVATED MANSLAUGHTER.
THOSE ARE THE FACTS.
THAT IS THE ENTIRE LIST FROM
2019.
LAST YEAR.
TEN DEATHS.
IN FIVE DEATHS AND OFFICER WAS
ATTACKED JUST BEFORE THE
SHOOTING OCCURRED.
THAT IS NOT DISPUTED.
ONE ALLEGEDLY WAS AN ACCIDENT,
THAT LEAVES A FULL TOTAL OF FOUR
CODEATHS IN PURSUIT OR A
STANDOFF.
AN TWO OF THOSE CASES, THE
OFFICER WAS CRIMINALLY CHARGED.
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT MORE OF
THESE OFFICERS SHOULD HAVE BEEN
CHARGED, OF COURSE IT’S
POSSIBLE.
JUSTICE IS NOT ALWAYS SERVED,
THAT’S FOR SURE.
BUT EITHER WAY, THIS IS A VERY
SMALL NUMBER IN A COUNTRY OF
325 MILLION PEOPLE.
THIS IS NOT GENOCIDE, IT’S NOT
EVEN CLOSE TO GENOCIDE, IT’S
LAUGHABLE TO SUGGEST IT IS.
THE NUMBER POLICE KILLINGS IS
DROPPING.
IN 2015 DURING BARACK OBAMA’S
PRESIDENCY, 38 UNARMED BLACK
AMERICANS AND 32 WHITES WERE
SLAIN BY POLICE, OVERALL TOTALS
HAVE FALLEN SINCE THEN AND
FALLEN FAR MORE DRAMATICALLY FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICAN MEN.
LAST YEAR WAS THE SAFEST YEAR
FOR UNARMED SUSPECTS SINCE
"THE WASHINGTON POST" BEGAN
TRACKING POLICE SHOOTINGS.
THE SAFEST YEAR FOR BOTH WHITE
AND BLACK SUSPECTS.
AT THE SAME TIME THIS COUNTRY
REMAINS A DANGEROUS PLACE FOR
POLICE OFFICERS, 48 OF THEM WERE
MURDERED IN 2019 ACCORDING TO
FBI DATA.
THAT’S MORE THAN THE NUMBER OF
UNARMED SUSPECTS KILLED OF ALL
RACES.
ONE FINAL NUMBER FOR YOU BECAUSE
IT MATTERS.
IN 2018, 7,407 AFRICAN-AMERICANS
WERE MURDERED IN THE
UNITED STATES.
IN 2019 CONTINUES ON A SIMILAR
TRAJECTORY AND WE HOPE IT
DOESN’T BUT IF IT DOES THAT
WOULD MEAN THAT FOR EVERY
UNARMED AFRICAN-AMERICAN SHOT TO
DEATH IN THE UNITED STATES BY
POLICE, MORE THAN 700 WERE
MURDERED BY SOMEONE ELSE.
USUALLY BY SOMEONE THEY KNOW.
AGAIN, THOSE ARE THE FACTS, THEY
ARE NOT IN DISPUTE.
OUR AFRICAN-AMERICANS BEING
HUNTED AS JOY REID RECKLESSLY
CLAIMED ON MSNBC RECENTLY?
OR SOMETHING ELSE HAPPENING?
IS OUR NATION BEING RIPPED APART
BY A TOTAL AND COMPLETE LIE,
APPROVABLE LIE, ALLY USED BY A
CYNICAL MEDIA MANIPULATORS AND
UNSCRUPULOUS POLITICIANS WHO
UNDERSTAND THAT RACIAL STRIFE
RAISED HATRED AS THEIR PATH TO